(Machine click)
♪♪
William:
I don’t know if this will get to
you, I hope so.
♪♪
William:
I can’t go back in time and fix
all of the mistakes that I made.
♪♪
William:
But maybe I can leave something
for the future.
(Eerie sound)
A legacy.
♪♪
Lee:
The world is on fire.
I decided to do something about
it.
♪♪
Lee:
Hopes. Dreams. Ambitions.
The mission was to protect their
world...
Lee:
The mission was to protect their
world... (Monster hissing)
Lee:
...and ours.
♪♪
Lee:
It’s what we wanted Monarch to
be.
♪♪
Lee:
Instead of chasing monsters.
(Water cascading)
If you come with me, you’ll know
everything, I promise.
(Large inpact)
(Growling)
(Shrieking)
♪♪
(Jet engines)
(Growling and crash sounds)
(People screaming)
(Explosion)
(Roaring)
(Intense music)